Coluche disait on est dans le pays de la
bouffe et de la gastronomie ce n'est pas
ici que des gens vont mourir de faim et
pourtant c'est bien ici que des gens
enfin autour de nous dans nos
circonscriptions partout dans le
territoire et de plus en plus 8 millions
de Français sont en situation de
précarité alimentaire avérée et un
Français sur cinq saute au moins un
repas par jour l'inflation sur les
produits alimentaires à atteint 15,8% en
allant à mars ce qui est inédit depuis
les années 80
[Musique]
Aché j'en profite pour vous répondre je
n'ai aucune aucune leçon à recevoir de
votre part j'ai passé 12 ans à m'engager
à la Croix-Rouge française je sais ce
que c'est que la misère je sais ce que
c'est la pauvreté je sais ce que c'est
les petits salaires je sais ce qui
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas
voilà et quand vous nous traitez de
mépris je crois que le mépris il est
chez vous quand vous avez ces propos là
et que vous me regardez dans les yeux
pour me dire ce genre de choses je n'ai
aucune leçon à recevoir de votre part
quel ministre a vous nous avez dit que
vous connaissiez la misère comment vous
pouvez regarder ces gens leur disant
face à l'inflation face à 30% de plus
sur les produits dont vous avez besoin
je vous offre la somme de 2 euros par an
par an c'est scandaleux
[Musique]